it sucks because I love JJ but
hello reject Nation
all right we are here for bad batch
episode four I am Michael Tessler
founder and CEO of multi-house joining
me today I'm not sure if you've met him
this is Greg
doesn't have a title Greg you excited
for this episode I'm reasonably excited
yeah reasonably excited I don't even
know if we're recording I just kind of
I think this is the intro now this is
the intro I think you should tell them
leave a like hey leave a like and uh if
you haven't already you should probably
subscribe and uh if you comment who
knows I might comment so do you know
what I say about the patreon uh you're
yeah uh well first off uh super sexy
rejects uh go to the patreon or keep
going on the patreon if you haven't
already uh there's some great content
full interviews some other wonderful
stuff you watch some pretty obscure
stuff like I see people in the comments
all the time like me watch attack of the
titans just Attack on Titan I don't know
Attack of the Titans
starting James Cagney
Debbie Reynolds anyway
so uh ready to dive in some Star Wars
all right let's roll that into it
God I hope we get to go to Tashi station
to pick up some power converters in this
episode faster harder better faster
stronger Roger Roger
this looks familiar oh I know that guy
he's always eating yes
oh I got you this time it's not Star
Wars unless you're playing the game
now you owe me two cartons of men's
helmets not so fast one more game rip
her arms off rip her arms off I got
another job for you Hunter and Echo back
from the other Mission yet oh
transporting 50 cases of Nerf nuggets a
mission nor is it a proper use of us I
want a Nerf nugget you are gonna be my
security what is the mission
zaphatoma can be a little rough around
the edges if you don't know what you're
doing got a little Sun Doula in the
background
that's what I call Pottery pod race
pod race
it's called Riot racing it's called Riot
racing in [ __ ]
oh my God
is it them the heads oh maybe the
announcers commentators
and tear away
I hope they do that if it is I hope they
do this
[Applause]
I think
one of the chests one of thrawn species
was in the background there I've never
seen one it's a boss lady
show depressing well
I love him I know this voice
not have enough information about this
sport to determine that at this time
then take a seat spectacled spectator
all right all right save it for the
course it's alliteration I was about to
save it for the course excuse me I can't
talk right now it's time I prepare for
the next race what's up Ben Schwartz is
it is it
I would watch a spin-off
artist
citizens
gamorion that's Motley Crue
thank you
oh you think your Droid can beat my
champ
what's he saying get lost slimo
let's see
what in The Phantom Menace is this
episode
this is
you're using the batch to solve your own
personal vendettas
[Applause]
[Music]
they had a version of this and Knights
of the Old Republic
having flashbacks right now
jet space corn dogs from the creators of
Nerf nuggets
what is the protocols right doing
driving
I swear that might be a chance
why would you want a front seat
[Laughter]
knows what he is doing what's wrong with
this whole race is a death trap yeah
there's like nothing's happening so they
can't animate all this but they can't
afford inviting it
got a bad feeling about this
[Music]
like the more cyberpunk Vibes yeah right
this is what Nascar should be
oh
no not the Gumdrop buttons the speedo is
in bad shape but some of it is
salvageable that's the least amounts now
goggles
give me some time I'm good for it that's
not how this works wanna step in here I
didn't bring you two for the company
punch him get him God he's like the
alien from Lilo and Stitch yes yes
that's I couldn't pinpoint it yeah how
much does she owe more than you got kid
well what about Nerf nuggets we're not
done yet
looks like you've done to me one last
race little Lanny
we pay you doubles we win
we get said
oh Sid's part of the family
do we have a deal we race tomorrow
and I keep sick as collateral God who's
that guy's voice I don't know but I love
him
with a few more adjustments he may be
capable of racing uh that is hilarious
more than capable I am ready to where
are my arms
that's what I wish jar jar had been
it's my kind of comic relief we should
be taking out that gangster this is not
the first time she has required our
assistance due to her dealings with
individuals of questionable Integrity it
is a problematic pattern did you forget
you're working on me how about a little
less chatter a little more spanner
nicely put I hope the tail ends up as a
permanent addition to the bad badge I
know it'd be nice it's nice having the
funny droids around yeah well there's
none so far in the show except for first
season but that was really sad Hustlers
like us never change
sooner or later those outcasts you're
hanging out with will get to know the
real sit I might surprise you she's
changed man
Omega has that effect on people and it's
really bugging me I can't pinpoint that
guy's voice
hey it went down a little bit the food
yes I can
when I will not make twice I don't think
a bite was
what is going on food is really
confusing me
maybe it's a comfort thing it's just
emotional support sausage
you are doing it
calculations won't help you it is all
about strategy and skill
it would be wise to divert power to the
reflector Shields from your primary
weapon system oh an amateur mistake
why Teo is your only chance at Victory
if you want to win out there offense is
the best
oh my God
what just happened
oh no
drugs what just happened
sophatoma is a danger
he's fine
not out of it regret
nothing
looks like a forfeit no racer means Sid
loses
tax season
we have to do something
be the racer yeah
yeah I've been wanting more Tech
you heard him that's still on I never
stop a fool from giving his life to make
me
I hope this is how they kill off Tech
yeah unceremoniously
oh if it's safe it's the trailer I want
more Tech
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta love the poses
oh
that's cool
and finally tag
s
[Laughter]
it's a comedian episode
us
so I love the mixed match uh droids
there that was fun
[Music]
oh this is exciting
[Music]
oh no they're so cute what place is he
in last but he's catching up
attack you gotta be in front to win
[Laughter]
I love wrecker
[Music]
come on
[Music]
yeah rave time yeah I want to do some
spice after this
did you just focus on not getting blown
up
oh yeah got attacked
[Music]
this episode's turning out a lot better
than I thought
it's learning to let go literally yeah
like Jean-Claude Van Damme kickboxer
camera love them
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
did Mario Kart's way more fun than I
remember
it's also the shortest time
to attack
fast enough we call you Tech Deck around
here yeah left Tech
attack
nice
oh my God it's so cramped in there
[Music]
go buddy
ah man
I'm right there with you
oh man
[Applause]
[Music]
the Enterprise
nice way done buddy
come on come on come on Tech Deck come
on
[Music]
let me sing hell yeah now this is Padres
I hope Tech leaves the batch behind to
pursue a lifetime career a varieties
ah I thought you were gonna
oh
[Music]
that's how I feel when people talk about
me in the comments cheers
we're square that was some recent
goggles yeah
it's not Keith David who is that voice
well I guess I owe you one
yes I would agree
I'll make it up to you I don't like the
gun on the bar
hey you three oh you could have walked
away
that loyalty is admirable watch your
backs
watch your back watch your Watcher watch
back
I feel like they just planted a really
important seed for this season
[Music]
you know what I'm not gonna lie this
show
every every time I'm like this is gonna
be trash this is gonna be a bad episode
which I have said
begrudgingly before every single episode
um
like we had character growth
we had fun I mean you and I were
literally on the edge of our seats
well I'm gonna lie this episode sucked
laughs
that was fun you know it I think it's
it's easy for episodes like this that
are you know
it could be filler but like I feel like
we had great development particularly
for Tech uh I thought it was really it
was also nice to separate the bad batch
a little bit and give everybody some
time to to breathe uh just like watching
The Chemistry Between wrecker and Tech
Ernie Hudson oh that makes so much sense
it was Ben Schwartz yeah okay I know
I hope you say Teo again but uh yeah no
I'm right there with you uh on the knock
on the live spectrum because this
started off like
all right I guess we're back to some we
gotta fill out some episode numbers here
don't we
get really engaging and really funny and
exciting and you know like with tech
getting in the field like everyone like
in the first second episode Tech got
more [ __ ] to do that was cool getting
him in the field and game shoot some
[ __ ] and then here he gets to get behind
the wheel and
um I haven't played High Republic you
said no nights
we don't we don't talk about the Hiram
yeah we do higher Public's loved so is
Picard season two and one
yeah but the the the the the situation
with tech was just so exciting and uh I
thought it was animated so well too like
it was visceral and the sound design is
what got me like it's so upgraded
cyberpunk version of pod racing no I do
that I know I mean I I wasn't kidding
when I said do you want to do spice
afterwards because like that's the kind
of like grungy like retro futuristic
Star Wars that I just like I love yeah I
got an Old Spice
yeah we could put it on our armpits
later if you want it
pulling out one though
you want to go home and rethink your
life
um no it's uh dude it's just it it's so
fun but I got a conspiracy theory
I think Sid is gonna be our connective
tissue to Maul and
all that fun stuff in the Star Wars
underworld wow that's a stretch uh I
because because you know it's ratchet
you're right you know it's coming though
like like the question is from which
angle
um you know and and I feel like setting
sit up is like way more ominous and
making bad deals with bad people I feel
like that would be a really interesting
way to throw the bad batch into that
World
um and like this time period for like
Mall in particular like this is like
right when Death Watch is and I've never
read the comics like is breaking him out
um you know because you know old palpi
has him still
um and uh you know and watching him
become more of a criminal element uh and
I just feel like that'd be really kind
of interesting to explore that side of
the Galaxy
well
I
like to explore those things I have a
hard time believing it would be with Sid
I just maybe not Sid directly but like I
think it was Sid mission
relationship puts them into that
criminal Circle so to speak fair enough
because yeah I think what they were
saying with Sid was something just a
little bit more personal and immediate
like oh Sid might betray them but then
doesn't should make some type of
more morally righteous Choice when they
don't expect her to because they've been
thinking maybe we shouldn't trust it and
they turn their back and then Sid shows
up and helps save them and so I was
thinking something more on those lines
what they were setting up I wasn't
really going to like Darth Maul
hop skip jump here all right maybe it's
not mall but maybe it's the equally
terrifying
like really threatening Star Wars
villain Hondo anaka you know it's like I
just you know I I can't help but feel
like there is a connective tissue there
um it would
as we get to the scarier stuff she's how
we explain snoke
all right conspiracy theory
she's Rey's real mother
it was all a cover-up Palpatine was
trying to protect her uh
no it's it's uh yeah they'll be
something interesting there I'm actually
surprised we haven't seen uh Hondo or
any of the me too yeah I'm waiting for
it every episode
I I'd like to I like to think that um uh
Jim Cummings uh Hondo's voice just
constantly text Dave filoni being like
hey you up
um but this episode in particular was
was the kind of episode that I thought
the comedy really worked because it's
easily is one of the sillier episodes of
the bad batch but sometimes the silly
ones in the first season were not my
favorite there was during growth there
wasn't any yeah there was no pulse to
them they were kind of bland silly like
they were like uh maybe a little kid
would enjoy this but this is Bland uh
this was like the like a really
family-friendly episode and yeah I had a
lot of jokes but to me it was not every
joke was Landing but it really started
to work for real I freaking just like
you have to go to the front to win yeah
and it's I thought Teo was great yeah
it's not always nice to see them do
something different with droids but that
still feels authentic to Star Wars
because sometimes they miss the Mark
um Disney has made droids funny yeah
which is you know I it's one of the few
things they've been doing right yeah no
that's that's true Phoebe Waller Bridge
so everyone would not stop raving about
Phoebe while in French
yeah I know like k2so ah no I I know I
mean it's a
this was nice because it plays on a
little bit of the Nostalgia I mean like
right from the get-go you're not
shouting pod racing at the same time and
um they were like everyone's gonna be
shouting pod racing we didn't clear up
what this is very quickly uh no but it
was it was nice and uh I love any time
that
you have that many background characters
there's just like I could re-watch an
episode like this clearly not for the
plot but for just like the Easter eggs
and the little uh it was it was really
fun to see you know I mean even there
was that moment when we were going back
and like almost to the exact outfit it
looked like Hera from Rebels
um I just like little things like that
to to catch you off guard and to keep it
interesting that I love well I enjoy Sid
as well I think Sid is the kind of
character that well that wasn't too
appealed to in the beginning but you
know she actually cares about them she's
just one she's one of those characters
kind of like have you seen Gravity Falls
yeah of course like Grunkle Stan that's
that's such a great where they're gonna
get you in trouble and put you into
precarious situations
[Music]
but they have a big part yeah
yeah I mean it's a fun character my only
problem is they just remind me of
everybody that I knew back home on Long
Island like
it's just that kind of like
I don't know but I'm sure they like they
can tell you where the best bagel place
is you know yes so that's where that's
what they meant by Sid yeah I it
probably is Hondo huh it's probably not
a ball and death watch but maybe it is
maybe it's connected is more important
than you realize yeah you know well
Sid's origin planet is dathomir is it no
no
yeah no what I I could have you could
have got off
holy [ __ ] maybe he's right it's all
connected uh no uh it's actually Sid Sid
was actually the one that enslaved
Chewie oh yeah that's wild
yeah we're gonna start spreading fake
Star Wars
welcome to real rejects are number one
swords for fake Star Wars news I'm just
happy for Tech though yeah I mean me too
my only worry is that because we're
spending so much time with tech uh that
the bad batch I mean if they're gonna do
what Rebels did every season gets a
little darker and a little grittier
and I wonder if we need to lose a member
of the bad batch in order to raise the
stakes
um and I feel like Tech would be a
the rest of the team would very much be
lost without him I feel like the morning
can get rid of his record but wrecker's
too funny you need you need that
or Echo
if they kill Echo I'm out that one would
be so funny I'm gonna I will go through
all that all like oh it goes back and
then they kill off yeah like if they
want to take another arm fine
but no not not Echo I I hope
I hope you know Echo being reunited with
some of the other clones
um is gonna be so much fun but well I
think what's really neat about this one
is this season so far has been feeling
like clone wars in the sense of the
first episode you're with the batch if
you don't see Crosshair and then here
the second episode's Crosshair you don't
see the protagonist at all and this one
there's no Hunter and there's no Echo
um right it gives yeah no it and it
gives them all time to breathe uh and
more Focus yeah it's nice which is you
know and what a smart use of Crosshair
too like
I not take I really didn't care for
Crosshair in season one what yeah I just
did like it the whole thing kind of fell
flat on me I feel like I didn't like
them enough in the subtle introduction
of the bad batch to make me feel like it
was a devastating portrayal like they
were always kind of a bag of dicks you
know
um but dude you should have saved that
opinion for when we got to the final
episode yeah and we didn't lose audience
no listen I oh he's a [ __ ] badass
don't get me wrong like no but but
you've done irreparable harm to the damn
have I have is this the end of the real
version sure John has made it to season
two of Clone Wars finally he's joining
me now
God man I
it is it is astounding that even like
the one-off episodes here like I went
back and I was watching season three of
Clone Wars last night
um and you know it's fun it was I wanted
to see Echo
um
pre
you know free body yeah we're not sure
what the
pre-human center or whatever the heck
happened to him uh
and like God even even on its like off
episodes the jump of Animation audio
engineering all of it is just like
it's mind bending it's it's just you
know
um I feel like they threw down for here
for bad batch too the season two's looks
so much better yeah well I mean I think
it's a a general
um
there there is so much story but tell a
story patelling tangentiality there's
story to tell okay story but you don't
even remember uh no there's so much
storytelling potential uh with animation
and I think that the um
you know the the
historically speaking
animation has been looked down upon and
has been kind of viewed as like purely a
children's medium and I feel like in the
last five years especially that's really
shifted on on the mainstream
um and Clone Wars I think had a big role
to play in that uh and I hope this means
that they're going to keep doing more
animated series
um because it's such a great way to I
mean
is the bad batch of story that needs to
be told
I don't know but I'm glad that they're
telling it and I feel like animation is
probably the best use of Studio
resources
alrighty guys well the bad batch season
two episode four Tech Deck Pee Wee trick
borders
I enjoyed this one Ben Schwartz keep him
around see if the headshot cross them
over let's get it done I want to see Teo
in
like
I want him to cut them in half and put
them on top of the bad Batch's ship and
just half a piece
a sip Droid for now on uh well reject
Nation this was fun uh hey if if you
think that that's it that's it is the
direct connection to Maul uh and Death
Watch comment below if you think that
I'm off my rocker and need to stop
watching Clone Wars at 3am
uh also maybe talk about that in the
comments I'll respond
I swear
[Music]